Hello Freak bitches think and I know
that black Sabbath is getting back
together with the original lineup to do
two shows at the Birmingham Nec in
England.
So I called Sharon Osborne.
I said,
Sharon,
I got this great idea.
I fly out and hang out with black
sabbath and bro down with a band and go
to band practice and have a really good
time and you put me on the guest list
for these shows and I hang out for free
and it's like the best time I've ever
had and knowing she'd hang up on me and
she said let me call him and ask him if
that's okay because I already knew it,
but I didn't know the rest of the guys
and she called me later that day.
She said,
oh,
they think it's fine.
Here's the address.
I'm just let us know when to expect you.
So I booked,
I booked it around my trip to Africa.
So I went a USA London bus up to Wales
where they were practicing a taxi?
No,
no,
the,
his assistant came and got me.
So I hung out with Sabbath at band
practice.
Me and the band in full band rehearsals,
the best,
uh,
watch the shows that you reunion shows
at the soundboard and then the next day
I flew to Kenya and so it was just a
good,
you know,
that was a good chunk of travel and I
ended up in South Africa after all of
that and said to myself,
okay,
I'm going to come to Africa once a year.
And I just started picking out different
chunks of it and it just started going
and that was 20 years ago and I've been
there,
I don't know,
like 20 sometimes.
Wow.
Yeah.
And you never don't learn it.
I call it the big book.
It's where you learned about life and
death and Oh,
you can learn that anywhere,
but you see big stuff.
You see people who suffer,
people who have no food or water
security.
Like you and I,
we talked about retirement and life
insurance and vacation.
They,
a lot of tribes,
there's no words or even ideas in their
lives.
Like I was hanging out with some
maturity people once in Uganda a few
years ago and I had a translators at
Dinka guy who spoke,
I guess whatever a truly people speak
and I said,
can you ask them if they have any words
in their language for life insurance,
retirement or a vacation?
And they understood retirement.
You get too old,
your kids take care of you,
but a vacation.
They said you leave somewhere and you
come back.
Why would you want to leave your home?
It's where all your friends are in your
family and you.
Why would you ever do that?
Or like life insurance,
like what the hell are you talking
about?
And you start meeting people who their
sense of time and space is,
I've got a bowl,
there's some rice in it.
So like today I got tomorrow,
we'll see where you and I think,
okay,
in December I'm going to do this and we
really have a realistic expectation of
being alive and breathing in December
and in your life.
You've no doubt thought of,
okay,
when I retire or whatever that means to
you money.
Some kind of security up the road,
there's parts of the world where people
live their entire life 37 years and then
they don't have a day of that kind of
security.
They got the t shirt,
a stick and some shade and I try and not
as some voitier I'm trying to understand
the world and I can understand it by
reading some books and seeing some
documentaries,
but there's nothing getting out into
what Mark Twain called the territory of
phrase I stole from David Lee Roth when
he said it to me.
And David Lee was actually a real
inspiration to do a lot of traveling
because one time we were talking and he
just come back from open sea kayaking in
the Pacific.
So I said,
so why is it Henry is because don't get
eaten today is a great thing to have on
your to do list every once in awhile.
I said,
damn,
that is profound.
You know what he was doing up until
recently he moved to Japan.
I didn't know anybody there and he was
taking Kendall lessons.
So learning how to sword fight the
Japanese master.
Yep.
But this dog.
No,
no,
he told me,
he called me one Sunday a while ago.
I helped him with this autobiography.
So I worked with Dave really closely for
many,
many months.
I met him when I was in black flag 30
some years ago.
Uh,
I walked by him at an art gallery.
I went,
wait a minute.
And he went black flag,
right?
No Way.
It's the van Halen guy.
We became best buddies,
but he called me from Japan and said,
uh,
you know,
he's learning Japanese.
He's very smart.
And he was like learning Japanese and
started speaking Japanese and he's just
taking lessons,
you know,
you said the sword guy was just like
everyday just like,
you're stupid.
He's just like,
just breaking them down.
Yeah.
And he just got an apartment there.
Yeah,
I mean there's loving rockstar just gets
like this normal apartment with his dog
and just starts taking Kendo lessons,
everything.
David's always had a greater
appreciation of,
of,
you know,
that kind of discipline in me comes up
through martial arts since he was a kid.
And I think as someone else in his
family's into it,
but he's been that way,
you know,
that kind of discipline and you can see
it on stage.
The guy is very physical,
but it's coming from a real disciplined,
not messing around kind of aggression
and control.
And I dave really loves Japan and he
says he called me and so I'm living in a
small apartment.
I'm taking my language lessons,
I'm taking my martial arts stuff.
And he was doing sword stuff for quite a
long time though.
Yeah.
He's always been involved in martial
arts.
And even the way he sort of approach to
hedonism,
I always felt like it was sort of like
an applied approach to hedonism,
like his rockstar lifestyle thing,
what he was doing.
It's almost like,
look,
not a lot of people get a chance to do
this.
Yep.
I'm going to do it.
Yeah.
One time he,
when we were working on his book,
he said,
you know,
I go home to Pasadena now.
And then were you born and raised in
some of his high school buddies?
Seemingly like,
well Dave,
you know,
it must be nice,
being David Lee Roth and he,
and he said,
you know what,
on graduation day from high school,
we all were on the same starting blocks.
You chose the bank job,
that's a sure thing.
You're going to die in that cubicle I
choose.
And he said to sail the seas of
consequence.
I was like,
I love that.
And I was like,
yeah man,
that's daring.
And so he won.
I mean,
like he said it pretty good ride.
I record and,
and so in my own way,
you know,
I come from minimum wage work,
I'm nobody from nowhere and I got into
music via punk rock because the band
black flag said,
hey,
you're a crazy guy.
You want to try out to be our singer.
I'm like,
what do I have to lose?
Yeah.
And so I went for that and it led to
everything else.
And ultimately why I'm here in this room
with you today.
Do you miss rock?
Do you miss touring as a musician?
No,
no,
because I did it.
I did it really hard until I had nothing
left to give to it and so now if I went
back to it,
it would just be repetition and it might
be fun repetition,
but it wouldn't be meaningful in that I
wouldn't be putting out anything new and
for me the day I stopped doing music was
I woke up one day and I just sat up and
he was like a,
a light bulb went on.
I went,
wow,
I'm out of lyrics.
And it wasn't like,
oh no.
I'm like,
okay,
well give me my scroll.
I guess I've graduated.
When was this?
A 2000,
three years that,
and I just call it the manager.
I said,
Hey,
I'm done with music.
And he saw 15 percent of that though,
poof.
And he's like,
no.
I went,
yeah.
He goes,
why?
I said,
because I got nothing new to add.
These will then just go out and do the
hits.
I'm like,
man,
that's not what coltrane would have
done.
It's not with miles Davis would've done.
I just can't.
I don't want to repeat.
It's not artistically brave to me.
And so I'd much rather just try new
things,
but thankfully by that time I was
already doing talking tours all over the
world and they do very well.
Tons of acting,
voiceover.
I had all this other stuff I was doing,
had the book company,
a record company,
music publishing.
I had all this other stuff and so I just
kind of let all of that stuff fill in,
put it this way.
I'm busier now than ever and I don't
miss the music.
I see bands in the airport all the time,
but like the laminates in road gear,
I'm like,
yeah,
rumble young man rumble.
I had my fill.
Well,
it's beautiful that you did it on your
terms.
You decided to do it.
It wasn't just,
it wasn't like there's a lot of aging
rock stars that have that sort of
existence where they have to go out and
do the hair.
No one wants to hear.
He knew shit.
That's a big part of the problem.
And so they have to do that weird circle
the wagons thing,
like we're going to play this album in
its entirety.
Okay.
I go to some of those shows,
uh,
I,
you know,
throwing my money down and go see that
band,
do that album in its entirety.
It's cool,
but it's not for me.
Well,
I've heard the stones still put on an
awesome show.
I think one of the cool things about it
is like,
wow,
mick jagger can still fucking do it.
He still apparently works out twice a
day.
Yeah,
he's amazing shame,
great shape.
Um,
there's some people and they're,
they're rare.
They actually,
it's not about money.
That's when I really start trusting
those old rock stars.
Like Rod Stewart doesn't need a dime.
I mean,
that guy can buy four countries right
now.
He's probably playing tonight and Las
Vegas or somewhere.
Elton John.
They just really liked doing the thing.
Mick Jagger and Keith Richards,
there'll be rocking.
They'll die on stage and it's not money.
It's not like,
hey,
we might get populous like,
man,
we really want to play brown sugar.
I don't,
but I admired them.
I think it's what I'm saying is I think
it's real.
Yeah.
Well I'm sure it is real.
I'm sure it's real with a lot of them,
but what I like with you with what
you're saying is that you had already
figured out all these other paths in
life that you were enjoying putting your
creative energy and just decided.
I just,
I,
I know it was summer 19,
84.
I was 23.
I was in black flag and we were touring.
We were staying out of California
because the Olympics were coming and we
knew the cops would just be looking to
smash down any supposed Ne'er do wells.
So we just stayed on tour the whole year
pretty much.
And I noticed all these great bands
around the very talented people and
ever.
We're all broke between tours were like
living like sharks.
If we don't like tour,
we don't eat.
And between tours,
the guys in that band,
they're all waiters.
I'm not putting that down and say,
but the music wasn't keeping you in rent
12 months a year and I'm not nearly as
talented as any of them.
So I said,
man,
if there those guys are struggling,
then what am I going to do?
I better get plans B,
c,
d,
e,
F and g together,
and in those days I just started my
little book publishing company,
so I'm going to work harder on writing.
I'm going to become much better.
Start doing the talking shows.
I'm going to get much better at that and
I'm going to start saying yes to things
when they come along.
A couple of years later,
Hollywood started calling,
Hey,
can you act them because well as I can
sing and click,
but I started,
you know,
acting is crispin glover,
the actor.
One day he said to me,
he said,
Henry as a just please consider acting.
Just like just if you get an audition,
don't necessarily say no just because
you're the music guy.
Like he said,
I think you might really like it and you
could probably do it.
And so I said,
okay,
and within a year I was doing film and
then,
Hey,
can you do a voiceover?
I'm like,
yeah,
I got a voice.
And so I just started saying yes to more
stuff and that was the plan.
Just have more things to do,
which is fine because I don't like
sitting around anyway and then
ironically music ended up being very,
very good in all of that for me.
But I had plans,
other plans and I've noticed that a lot
of old geezers around my era,
they didn't come up with something else
and they just,
I don't know why and they didn't make
another plan and they get put into those
weird tours were there.
He,
you know,
you bring your kid all of that and it's
more that they got more than they want
to and I'd rather wake up wanting to do
stuff not having to do stuff.
I think like you were saying a while
ago,
like less obligation just so you clear
the deck so you can really do what you
want because life is short.
I mean last week I was 20 and now I'm
56.
I mean it goes by really fast.
It doesn't matter if you're in a cubicle
or a prison cell and then you wake up
one day,
you're like,
damn,
that was fast,
and so you might as well make it as much
as what you want it to be as possible
because all you're getting is older.
I don't understand why people don't fear
that I wake up every day,
but with the,
uh,
the grim reaper side whistling by my ear
going,
you better get up man.
And it's all the up I need.
I don't ever sleep in.